imaginez qu'une soucoupe volante
s'écrase près d'un terrain de foot alors
l'extraterrestre sort de son vaisseau il
essaie d'être discret mais là un joueur
de foot s'approche le tir de force sur
la pelouse
il nous manque un joueur mais ce maillot
et ramène toi tu es vous à la place de
l'extra terrestre
il est le seul sur terre ne pas savoir
ce qu'est le foot il ne comprend pas la
raison d'être
l'esprit de ce jeu et bien sûr ils en
ignorent les règles
bref il va à droite à la catastrophe
même s'il ya des pouvoirs il sera
forcément très mauvais parce que pour
bien faire il faut comprendre ce qu'on
fait si on épreuve de dissertation que
vous êtes comme les freins terrestre
qu'on tire de force sur le terrain de
foot
alors vous allez vous réclamez vous
devez d'abord vous poser la question
qu'est ce qu'une dissertation
si la plupart des élèves a rappelé leur
dissertation s'il souffre pendant
l'épreuve et redoute l'exercice c'est
tout simplement parce qu'ils ne le
comprennent pas pour répondre à la
question qu'est ce qu'une dissertation
je vais d'abord vous expliquer d'où
vient cet exercice parce qu'il n'est pas
tombé du ciel il ya en fait des racines
très ancienne mais ensuite vous dire
quels sont les enjeux fondamentaux de
l'exercice de la dissertation
c'est à dire ce qu'il faut faire en
dernière instance pour le réussir
et enfin je terminerai par vous parler
de l'état d'esprit nécessaire pour
réussir vos épreuves de dissertation à
la fin de cette vidéo vous saurez
exactement quoi faire pour progresser en
dissertation et si vous voulez
progresser rapidement
je vous conseille de vous inscrire à mon
cours gratuits de méthodologie le lien
doit s'afficher maintenant en haut à
droite de la vidéo
vous pouvez aussi le trouver dans la
description c'est un cours par e-mail
donc vous pouvez regarder cette vidéo en
entier puis vous découvrirez mais
méthodologie après ou un autre jour
voila voila on peut commencer
première chose pour réussir l'exercice
de la dissertation vous devez savoir
d'où il vient
écoutez bien ce que je vais vous dire et
la dissertation n'aura plus aucun secret
pauvres
je vais vous raconter rapidement
l'histoire de la dissertation
écoutez bien parce que ça va vous
permettre de comprendre l'esprit de
l'exercice et ça comme je vous l'aï dit
c'est crucial pour réussir alors d'où ça
vient la dissertation les origines les
plus anciennes ce sont des techniques
oratoires de l'antiquité
vous connaissez les sophistes c'était
des profs d'itinérants qui sont devenus
célèbres un thème à peu près à la même
époque que ce crac
c'était surtout des preuves de
rhétorique c'est à dire qu'il enseignait
l'art de persuader par la parole et le
renseignement est une racine de
l'exercice de la dissertation parce
qu'ils apprenaient à leurs élèves à
examiner une question sous tous les
angles
l'objectif c'était de les rendre
capables de défendre n'importe quel
point de vue le pour le contre
ou même des positions intermédiaires là
je pense que vous voyez le rapport avec
la dissertation quand on disserte on
réfléchit à une question
partant du principe qu'on ne connaît pas
la vérité on va découvrir la vérité ou
plutôt s'en approcher au fur et à mesure
qu'on réfléchisse il ya même une
technique des sophistes qui est à
l'origine du fameux plan thèse antithèse
synthèse c'est la technique dite des
discours double elle consiste à soutenir
successivement deux points de vue
opposés c'est à dire à peser le pour et
le contre
toujours dans l'objectif de s'approcher
de la vérité cette technique des
discours doublé liée à une autre origine
l'historique de l'exercice de la
dissertation la dialectique des
philosophes à dialectique en pratique
c'est un échange
méthodique de parole entre deux
interlocuteurs
vous savez c'est la manière dont ce
krach parler à des mecs vous lui disais
un truc à la con des as mais tu crois
vraiment l'autre rebondissait et la
conversation de progresser comme ça de
rebondissement en rebondissement
là encore je pense que vous voyez le
rapport avec la dissertation votre
raisonnement doit progresser de position
opposition et chaque position doit
entraîner naturellement la suivante
en fait la dissertation simule une
conversation entre deux personnes
intelligentes qui examine une question
avec une certaine ouverture d'esprit
voici pour les origines anciennes de
l'exercice de les dissertations
maintenant je vais évoquer rapidement
deux origines plus récentes
la première c'est l'enseignement de la
rhétorique dans les facultés du moyen
âge comment ça se passait eh bien on
débattait à propos d'un autre
devant un auditoire c'est ce qu'on
appelle la disputatio qui veut dire
examen discussion cette racine de
l'exercice de la dissertation elle
révèle l'importance de l'argumentation
vous écrivez une dissertation pour
convaincre pour persuader il ya deux
dimensions 2d d'origine récente de la
dissertation en france c'est l exercice
de recrutement des profs au 19e siècle
elle est devenue une épreuve du bac en
1864 mais avant on la pratique et
surtout dans les meilleurs lycées
parisiens pour préparer les élèves aux
concours
à partir de là la dissertation s'est
étendu aux autres disciplines histoire
droit économie etc
plus elle s'est imposée comme l'exercice
par excellence des futurs cadres du pays
dans la fonction publique les
professions libérales et intellectuelles
pourquoi est ce qu'il est utile de
connaître cette origine parce qu'elle
révèle que la dissertation est un
exercice difficile
autrefois réservé à une élite
intellectuelle
c'est ce que je rappelle aux élèves qui
m'écrivent romain je comprends pas j'ai
vu tous tes articles de méthodologie
mais je suis pas passée de 8 à 18 ans
dissertation vous n'allez pas passer de
8 à 18 du jour au lendemain parce que
c'est un exercice difficile qui demande
de se préparer avec soin en particulier
vous devez connaître et maîtriser les
enjeux fondamentaux de l'exercice
[Musique]
il ya tellement d'élèves qui me demande
mon avis sur des points de détail
romain il faut mettre le numéro des
parties entre parenthèses dans l'
annonce de plan romain il faut des
questions entre les transitions romain
c'est une bonne idée d'utiliser cette
référence
romain tu es sûr qu'il faut sauter une
ligne avant l' annonce de plan je
réponds toujours la même chose fait bien
la différence entre l'essentiel et
l'accessoire parce que si vous vous
focalisez sur des détails c'est à dire
sur l'accessoire alors vous perdrez
probablement de vue l'essentiel
or pour réussir votre dissertation il
vous suffit de réussir l'essentiel
est-ce que c'est essentiel de préciser
deux numéros de la partie dans l'
annonce de plan bien sûr que non est-ce
que c'est essentiel de citer tel ou tel
auteur peut y avoir des exceptions mais
très généralement non regardez par
exemple ce que dit le rapport du jury de
la chaussée de 2018
la présence de telle ou telle référence
dans une copie n'a aucune valeur soit
pas plus que le nombre de citations
seule compte la pertinence de l'usagé
qui en est fait dans le cadre d'une
argumentation suivi donc pour savoir ce
qu'est une dissertation et pour réussir
cet exercice il faut se demander qu'est
ce qui est essentiel en dissertation et
bien je vais vous le dire il y à deux
enjeux fondamentaux en dissertation
premier enjeu la réflexion second enjeu
l'expression pour réussir une
dissertation vous devez réfléchir et
vous exprimer et efficacement pour être
plus précis disserter ça consiste à
résoudre un problème intellectuel et vos
éléments de résolution vous devez les
présenter clairement et vous devez
convaincre votre lecteur c'est à dire le
correcteur qui sont pertinents alors
bien sûr vous devez aussi avoir un
minimum de connaissances mais ça n'est
pas du tout la priorité parce que la
dissertation n'est pas un contrôle de
connaissances plein d'élèves qui
connaissent leurs courses ou le bout des
doigts se ramasse en dissertation et
inversement il n'est pas rare que des
élèves cartonne avec peu de
connaissances c'est juste qu'ils
réfléchissent et s'expriment efficace
voilà vous n'avez pas besoin d'en savoir
plus
oubliées donc les détails réfléchissez
efficacement sujet écrivez clairement et
vous allez cartonné enfin c'est presque
sûr parce qu'il ya encore une chose que
vous devez savoir sur l'exercice de la
dissertation
pourquoi est ce qu'il y a des
dissertations partout dans le système
scolaire français
et bien parce que c'est un exercice bien
pratique qui permet de tester plusieurs
compétences à la fois ça va bien comme
je viens de vous le dire à la réflexion
et à l'expression mais pourquoi est ce
que je vous dis ça pourquoi est ce que
je me positionne du point de vue du
système scolaire
c'est pour vous encourager à être
pragmatique vous ne rédigent et pas un
article vous n'écrivez pas dans les sept
films de filles d'histoire l'économie ou
de droit vous faites simplement un
exercice qu'un prof corrigera quelques
minutes
autrement dit la dissertation est un
exercice scolaire
je répète pour que ça rentre la
dissertation est un exercice scolaire de
cette vérité vous pouvez tirer trois
conséquences pratiques
première conséquence comme le système
scolaire récompenser les bons élèves
vous devez simplement montrer que vous
en êtes à votre objectif c'est
uniquement de faire un bond de voir des
corps contentez vous donc de suivre les
règles du jeu du mieux que vous pouvez
deuxième conséquence du fait que la
dissertation est un exercice scolaire ne
cherchait pas à être original n'essayez
pas d'impressionner le correcteur parce
que votre texte ne l'intéresse pas et ne
lui apprendra rien troisième
conséquences qui découlent des deux
précédentes travaillé comme un bon élève
préparez-vous avec soin mais de manière
très pragmatique
les élèves qui cartonne en dissertation
sont les plus pragmatiques ils ont
démystifié la matière les preuves et
l'annotation ses élèves connaissent très
bien les règles du jeu et il travaille
uniquement pour la main une vérité qui
dérange mais le but de l'exercice de la
dissertation
c'est bien d'avoir la meilleure note
possible et si vous voulez décrocher la
meilleure note possible
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie par e-mail le lien doit
s'afficher de maintenant en haut à
droite de la vidéo mais vous pouvez
aussi le trouver dans la description
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que vous devez retenir
de cette vidéo
première chose la dissertation est un
exercice difficile autrefois réservé à
une élite intellectuelle
ne croyez donc pas que vous allez
réussir une dissertation parce que vous
avez lu votre cours pendant deux heures
deuxième chose à retenir les deux enjeux
de la dissertation ce sont la réflexion
est l'expression écrite ne confondez pas
l'exercice de la distorsion avec
d'autres exercices n'est pas un contrôle
de connaissances un commentaire ou
encore un résumé le but de cet exercice
c'est d'évaluer votre capacité à
réfléchir à une question complexe et à
vous exprimer efficacement allait enfin
troisième et dernière chose à retenir
rester scolaire voilà maintenant vous
savez ce qu'est une dissertation vous
avez posé les bonnes fondations pour
réussir vos prochaines épreuves
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu et
qu'elle vous sera utile si vous avez des
questions n'hésitez pas à laisser un
commentaire et puis souvenez vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour réussir une dissertation
[Musique]